hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the floor is jelly a game
then might might be a bit hard and might
might cause me to break just a little
bit and before I get too tongue-tied
here I'm gonna start the game either way
as a game that just came out on Steam
not too long ago and I don't know what's
happening right here am I supposed to be
doing something did I break the game
okay oh hi hello how are you my name is
markiplier you are a spherical jelly
ball and what am I supposed to do with
you well this is a lovely conversation
we're having here but I need I got a
show to run
I got a hundreds of thousands of people
watching this and they have no idea what
we're looking at you oh I can move you
but this doesn't have anything to do
with why the floors are all God hi oh
that's so pretty
Wow okay this is where all the color
came in now the screenshots that I was
watching actually did reflect that the
game was very colorful bright and
although the main menu may not have
explained it very well this is the first
time I'm playing it so I have no idea
what to expect other than that it might
be a little bit cool look at that okay
well I'm different whoa oh that's
awesome Wow like that Alivio Oh again
went backwards okay so Boing Boing Boing
what if floor is jelly wait oh I
confused myself of that bird there was
that even a bird okay there is there are
definitely birds that I'm shaking out
trees oh this is a little bit wonky oh
God oh that's okay cool
oh it didn't work that time but that's
okay there we go here we go got it got
it got it I'm in it to win it
ah yeah nope what's with that bird oh
that's a frog over there okay yeah I get
it you're a tutorial you're trying to
tell me what to do I already knew what I
was supposed okay wait thank you
god damn it
I know this might be a bit challenging
down the road but I might might not be
ready to be angry Justin right now okay
that looks like bad jelly set man jelly
to go rotten a while ago I don't really
care got it moving through these levels
fast must be my incredible level of
skill after playing all those rage
platformers that's gonna take some
getting used to it take Scott damn it
damn you ty how can I please get up okay
they can oh don't bounce me off the top
level I want to get to the top you son
of a [ __ ] stop Jillian me around okay
so I need to get up up no up I said up
up why are you not popping
why do you sometimes up and what are you
sometimes not up so the make any damn
sense you son of a [ __ ] okay I really
don't know what I'm doing I'm actually
trying to figure it out I why okay I all
cakes suddenly there I shot up like a
rocket okay so I got a wait a bit longer
dumb all the way down at the apex okay I
got the hang of it now
that was this fake I wasn't really angry
there the real anger is to come so just
you all wait yo yo yo day you'll pay
he'll take up there we go okay I'm
getting the hang of it remember guys I'm
learning the ropes here just so long as
you stay patient with me I can okay okay
okay okay just so long as you stay
patient with me we're gonna get through
this just fine so don't you worry about
little me I'm the best
okay dad but that's besides the point
first death I haven't died yet so
obviously I'm still the best and all
these platform games we okay don't bow
okay I need to bounce over there I
thought I may have been able to go over
to it under that but and apparently not
god this is pretty it's such a mellow
soundtrack and it's gonna be really
offset by my enormous screams of rage
but besides that god this really pretty
look at breathe okay how much okay how
am i ha ha
I don't know a game you're playing there
I need to go back no don't understand am
I supposed to go higher
maybe fight ok now is death how the hell
am I supposed to go oh wait wait what I
have an idea
yep Northy no okay those two Oh how did
I do that how did I do that I want to
know did I did it like jelly down enough
that I could actually pass through it I
have no idea
uh-huh-huh who's gonna kill me you saw
it it's trying to kill me ah yeah I know
your secrets now I know what you want me
to do it will be okay never mind thought
that was gonna loop around but
apparently not okay so I can go over you
if I bounce the top one up enough well
ok death death is an alternative to
success but not a good one
yep yep okay right into the death die if
I could just avoid that and go under it
okay alright it's gonna take me a while
oh yeah Wow get some I'm new this okay
made it I'm the best thank you
okay we're going to a whole nother level
area this game is actually pretty fun I
gotta admit the charm of it is very nice
I mean with these 2d platformers
obviously it's hard to get something
unique I am underwater holy crap I am
suddenly oh my goodness okay not quite
able I'm not underwater I'm just in the
cave where am I
I have no idea but either way with these
2d platforms I mean there's a lot of
them obviously it's a pretty popular
game style to make and it can be hard to
differentiate between the two but I mean
are the two between all the different
types of 2d platforms that they have so
they usually need something added on to
the experience to make it more
interesting but this I gotta say look
it's really working for me I like it a
lot there's a lot of uh there's a lot of
artistic styling to it in the simplicity
now I'm a fan of mental minimum
minimalism I could even talk like a
normal human being I'm a fan of
minimalism as it is and I like the
minimalistic style of this not
that is important in all games some
games actually do work with graphics but
the 2d platformer style has actually
been benefited by a lot of these
pixelated style games not necessarily
like the pixelated horror god damn you
tah Hal I'm a professional game reviewer
by the way if you couldn't tell
but either way a lot of letting style
games have benefited from having the low
res style but this is kind of a
combination of the low res style and
just pure simplicity which I thoroughly
enjoy I don't know don't know where the
music went because I was actually
enjoying the really mellow soundtrack
that was being provided before but oh my
goodness
there it is there it is you know one of
my favorite things about um I don't even
know why I'm bringing it up now but one
of my favorite things about Minecraft
was always the music like I love just
low my goodness wow what was that I
released a tapeworm type thing what is
that gonna do for me how does that
benefit me I don't know but we're gonna
find out but I really enjoyed like just
a simple adventure of it just living out
in the world and having that just be a
part of the experience like the music
was just something that brought it all
together
I mean without it it would it wouldn't
have felt so lonely at times it would
have wouldn't have felt so incredible
and I'm actually could I just noticed
I'm causing trees to grow as I won't run
across it that's really cool but I mean
something about the music in a game like
this it's so engrained in the actual
game itself combined with say the
graphics or the gameplay that it's a
factor that's often overlooked I mean
it's like not only in just these type of
games been in horror genres you know
it's often very overlooked and hearing
the same type of horror music in every
single game that I play really detract
from the experience so I really like the
fact that this has such a mellow
adventurous dick like exploration
soundtrack it's so light and crisp and
cool and I'm gonna I'm getting to way
deeper than my normal commentary which
is oh this is hard
woo but I mean it sometimes it's
important to like understand it you know
these games do have heart and soul to
him like the developer spends a lot of
time to bring out their artistic style
and like give me hard to like deliver an
artistic style while at the same time
trying to make a game that's fun and a
lot of like okay
I died there thank you very much so long
he's got my tapeworm here to join up
danger right but either way it can be
hard for a lot of developers who are
trying to express themselves to really
get something that's cool but I like
this really cool I'm waxing
philosophical here and I really
shouldn't be considering it once again
there's me talking here but I mean at
the same time I really I like I respect
the fact that it can as opposed to some
games that just do for the sake of doing
as opposed okay never mind I can't talk
and try to concentrate the same time let
alone talk okay yeah but we're seeing it
on the thing thank you thank you very
much
okay so anyway I don't even remember
what I was saying something important
but apparently not that important
because I can't remember what it was but
either way um something about a camp it
can be hard to actually represent all
that at the same time okay so I think
I've gone through that middle one week
didn't didn't I bounce up here just
recently didn't I just come through this
way or did I go through the all the
wrong one over there a piss balls I did
oh no wait no I didn't know no wait
maybe I did huh
okay that was not my fault I've probably
hard to see my character at this moment
with these three snakes behind me why do
I need the snakes why are the snakes
here why do I need them
oh sure I don't know what shog means but
ah blood for the blood god shagged
listen to me I don't know what that's in
his name
I remember what his name is it's all
that Warhammer Lord that I don't know
anymore oh well whatever that has
nothing to do with this gamer what I was
sorry about before I was like a bro a
lot of people were like oh wow more
blaring see something interesting to say
and then Olson fish goddammit I can't
remember what I was gonna say oh I died
blah blah
okay so I'm trying to remember but it
was just generally talking about how the
game and how the how the other game
feels it's very important to the player
experience like it's not just like woo
high score god damn it [ __ ] right
back it's not just to do with like God
if you can just go operate I could be
sophisticated shut up
lemme go you son of a [ __ ]
I don't even know what I'm supposed to
be doing with these a hole worms that
are obscuring my vision and making it
harder for me to see what I'm doing but
either way huh it's the feel of the game
that's important not always just who
high-score ooh
killer graphics ooh but I mean it's all
subjective of those things and who
really knows what people really like I
don't know ah if you two died there I
would have been so angry did I get all
four ah there's another one well that
was cool don't know where the other one
is but I gotta go back and find him
Simon Dewar's your BAE i'ma do your sh
okay so maybe it wasn't down this way
maybe it was down or yeah ah there was
one right dah
so I don't need to go back all the way
up there I just need to go back to the
beginning of the entrance over here
and I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it
see I've actually got the bounce
mechanic relatively down watch as I say
that and then I die
all of a sudden again no not at all da
ah thank you okay so anyway haha thank
you all so much for bearing with me
through that but do you like it's a feel
again it's important blah blah blah wait
a minute no wasn't it just here no yes
no wait a minute
didn't I come through here did I did
does it all wait wait a minute no I got
a glowy thing oh so this is like a hob
and I'm supposed to okay so I conquered
that area and now I need to find another
one maybe that's why this place is no
music and it's kind of underground II
watery weird I don't like it's different
I don't like things that are different
I am a sheep Oh
well Easter egg donor oh it was yes yes
Oh wasn't easter egg but it was where I
supposed to go either way
ha ha I thought there might have been
death that's from my old Megaman days
you know where you're testing out pits
just to see if there's anything in them
just in case cuz you never know you
never know
ok nothing up there ok jiggle-jiggle
Moin Moin Moin it is really cute though
yeah I admit it's cute see it's very
cute amazing mulling ah death boring
boring dead
thank you oh it's getting musical I love
it oh I love it it's getting so ok died
alright I didn't have to fall all the
way down but I think the game sense that
I was having some happiness and it
decided to take that away from me
I'm pretty sure that's what happened
there but no I love it when it when
music is incorporated with the level
design it's really cool
wow that brain good again on the time
that's good enough we we I am having a
lot of fun I gotta admit I'm having a
ton of fun with this game we I don't
know I'm not gonna play much longer like
mostly these first looks that I do I
don't play them to completion I just
play them to give you guys an idea if
it's worth your money cuz that's more
important like if this if this game to
you guys is worth it is what these
videos were all about cuz I love seeing
independent projects like this I love
any games I've always loved any games
and I kind of got away from playing a
bunch of them for a while there I used
to be all about playing them all the
time but any horror yeah I'll play those
but I mean those are hardly the same
thing
oh god oh those are only the same thing
when it comes to games like this but oh
dang it
this might be a bit tricky whoa
bowing Thank You me okay God got fried
drank okay all right we're gonna ignore
her okay we're gonna ignore any of that
happen this game definitely detected by
happiness levels were rising as we all
know I have one of those advanced model
computers ah I don't even know why that
happened that shouldn't happen I've one
of those advanced model computers that
plugs directly into my bloodstream and
detects my happiness levels and then it
pulls it right out to fuel my internet
bill which is very expensive
oh okay anyway so yeah it's game cool I
think I said all that I wanted to say
let me just play a little more
Boing Boing bowing my name is Marley I
was gonna rotate with me they are how
their II wait a minute there's secret
ones over there now are those yeah oh
yeah sure oh good it responding me there
would have been oh okay I've gotten very
bad keep I keep cursing to shag if you
know what I mean oh god damn it I'm
never gonna be able to do god damn and
I'm never gonna be able to do it again
oh thank you
Oh table baloney
wait wouldn't this wouldn't this be much
easier if I did it like this okay maybe
I'm an idiot well I guess I was never in
question because I didn't even die I
just fell down to the very bottom that I
could go that it would take me longer to
do if you could stop being a jack bag ah
there we go now that we're being all
polite to me and happy and fun and free
maybe now we could okay maybe now we
could okay thank you did I make it home
my jelly home the supposed to be in
California because it's protected
against earthquakes Oh yuck yuck yuck
what am i doing with this
I made it home I did it I won I did it
guys yeah actually this will be a good
stopping point because it's Betty who's
been about a little over 50 minutes so
either way this has been the floor is
jelly
I believe it's $8 on seam now I don't
know how long this game is but if you're
a fan of puzzle platforms with a little
bit of charm and great music give this a
try it's got a lot to it I haven't even
touched the surface of it but I already
like it a lot so if it's worth it to you
you there's a link in the description
for you to get the games really thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more awesome games that I
played in the past whole bunch of them
check them out
click the you do that thing I said don't
the thank you and as always I will see
you in the next video bye
forever and get totally distracted from
I'm doing which is probably means that
I'm going to play